I lovers more than I ever have I could
not live with my life without her we've
been married for 42 years
I first met Louise in our accounting
class our senior year in high school I
always heard her laughing behind me I
turn around and I see the gorgeous smile
actually we were on the opposite sides
of the classroom really hadn't noticed
him too much I was in the middle of two
other young men part of what caught his
attention that you know we were having
such a great time back there and that
wasn't included French being really
strict so our first date I said oh we're
gonna go look at a college in Pasadena
so that would allow her parents to say
okay since you're gonna go there I'll
let her go with you and and I think
that's when I told you I love you my
answer was sure 45 years later I still
love her
I forget many times the hardships he was
always a very hard worker and gone a lot
that would bother me because I almost
felt like a single parent at times I
knew that God put us together and wanted
us to work this out most of our time
have been financial but we were together
and we said well we'll get through this
we have faith thinking back at 20 I
didn't think it was young we knew what
we wanted to do and we were ready
now that would be able to put things
side by side it shows we had a wonderful
trip along the way because we're still
married and we're still happy
[Music]
I still look as happy as I did forty two
and a half years ago look at that the
symbol of what ring and what it meant
made it for real that wow I finally am
married I feel like I was more nervous
than about the day and the same feeling
but it did bring back a lot of memories
it also reminds me how blessed I am that
after 42 years I'm still with my wife I
thank God that he allowed me to find
this woman and enjoy a lifetime together
[Music]
[Music]